so I just now notice that the aspect
ratio is long and the slides are a
little clipped off I said we
with that and hopefully it will not be
too intrusive so it was a great pleasure
to be here some of you may know I did my
undergrad here and biking over here from
my friend's house I once again the
campus has changed so much I almost get
lost coming down this down this thing I
don't think Tresidder
sorry determine engineering is there
anymore like that's very sad yeah I
thought I saw that Pitt nough said oh my
god I think I used to be German so
that's that was my my childhood here all
gone so I've been enjoying being at
working in the haptics area since I
started my PhD at MIT in 1990 and when
it was a new thing we didn't call it
haptics and we called it well my
supervisor will Durfee said Karen won't
you come back and do your PhD in this
new thing where we're going to take
robots and have them touch people
instead of other stuff and do you think
that sounds cool I said yeah that sounds
kind of interesting and so no one had
really done this before I just
recognized someone in the audience how
exciting oh my god into interval
research is here what a great surprise
okay so so anyway okay so so we started
haptics and so that was a quite a long
time ago right at the very start which
really came out of robotics engineers at
MIT where the first work and of course
has spread quite a bit since then and
from quite early on I was very
interested in not big expensive machines
but how you could make it small in cheap
and universal and accessible to people
and this was when I was at MIT and in
robotics at MIT I worked with a lot of
other graduate students and I think that
there was a kind of a culture there
which was that your personal worth was
directly proportional to the number of
degrees of freedom in your robots that
you built and and so I was working on
knobs so I was pretty low on the pecking
order and so my life work has become to
justify knobs and knobs are cool and
knobs are hard and there
actually the complexity is not in the
mechanics necessarily but in all the
stuff you have to do to make the
mechanics comprehensible to people and
the reason I like nobs was because you
could make them small and cheap and
robust and out in the world and that was
actually a feasible objective so we'll
see how we're doing that was 20 years
ago and so we've been working on
designing these this haptic technology
for quite a while now if I can count
we're coming on darn close to 30 years
since some of the very first papers and
patents were actually going out there
for rendering or that just this idea of
being able to display a virtual
environment and so the technology is
actually finally finally finally
starting to be out there sometimes in
forms that I as a connoisseur do not
feel totally excited about or
enthusiastic about but still people
start to know what the word is they know
that haptic is not a liver disease and
and and it's more familiar people have
usually seen it in their games but
there's a huge obstacles to actually
using it as a design medium it is not at
a place where even if somehow somehow a
company has managed to put haptic
actuation into a product that their
design team is able to make it feel good
make it meaningful or comprehensible in
the context of an application because we
just do not have the design guidelines
the design knowledge and there's many
obstacles there's many reasons for why
that's such a challenge
so designing with haptic is different
than designing with other modalities
other since three modalities there's
ways it's the same we have some of the
same challenges the same processes we
use and there's ways that it's actually
it has its own specific challenges its
own idiosyncrasies that make it
particularly difficult and I feel like
at this point in my career I have
started to bash my head against these
problems enough that I have something to
say about it have something to share and
I am now trying to collect that
knowledge and make it more available to
people and one of where it comes down to
is have tissues need tools but we
actually first need to understand what
it is that happed ich UNS do that they
actually need to have supported and so
one context I have so I've been an
academic researcher for quite a
and so we think about all the stuff that
we do in the haptics world and so you
guys are all HCI researchers and so you
do something you'll recognize these
things but I just want to quickly make a
point that you'll recognize we do
interaction design so this is just some
pictures from some of the research over
the years we might be sequencing human
robot interaction or trying to figure
out what happens when you touch a
wearable display or a communication
protocol for a mouse of vibrates you
know some of this stuff goes way back
but basically interaction design like
what would happen if you actually put
haptics into it and what is the story
the narratives that a user is going
through we do a lot of prototyping okay
a lot of the prototyping in my lab is
what we call haptic sketching so quick
and dirty rough sketches trying to get
stuff very fast to the extent of
building it out of Lego or RC motors
remote-control car motors - you know
engineering prototypes it might take
several years to build but we're trying
to answer some question that way but
these prototypes take a while to build
or we do evaluation sometimes very
arduous difficult complex evaluation
setups where we're trying to reproduce
with some amount of control some
realistic context one of the funniest
recent ones was when we're actually
trying to evoke real emotion in a lab
setting without actually inflicting
damage on anyone and so so just kind of
the links we have to go to to construct
these things I might easily my students
might spend a year constructing an
experiment where we're trying to learn
something and I'm sure that this is not
a foreign concept to some of you okay
and then we have all kinds of data every
experiment we're doing unique kinds of
analysis the whole point I'm trying to
make here which is probably not a
surprise to you is that we take a lot of
time and effort and creativity to take
every little an ounce of knowledge a bit
further and if you're an industry this
is completely not available to you okay
this is not something there's not a
luxury that you have you have one shot
at it you have to deliver a prototype in
a month how do you actually leverage all
this knowledge and all this care and all
this love and creativity that we've been
doing in academia and say so what should
I do to make this
thing actually work and this is a big
knowledge gap that we've really been
struggling to get over with so so let's
look at design process so I'm the first
to start it this is going to look
extremely boring in an original stuff
you've seen before I'm trying to design
a haptic interaction what do I have to
do there's these different stages of
design that we go through that are
broadly correct accepted although many
different names
I'm not specifying anything about the
order you might go through or many all
these other things about design
framework that you guys want to add to
this but there's some basic design
activities that happen over and over by
any kind of designer any time browsing
through examples trying to get
inspiration the process of creating and
ID ating conceptualizing iterating
refining trying to test and evaluate and
see if it works and how it works and how
to do it better and of course the many
forms of sharing which include sharing
for the purpose of evaluation for
sharing for feedback showing to your
venture capitalists or your boss or your
client or even sharing into places that
other people can browse so that you're
actually kind of populating the
ecosystem with examples these are all
things that we do when we design but all
of these things are really hard to to in
haptics because of these special
characteristics of haptics so if we try
and take a deep dive into a couple of
these so browsing is one area that is
particularly difficult with haptics
because when you're browsing you're
looking at collections of examples if
you're trying to build a new website
probably the first thing that a lot of
people would do is they go I'm going to
look at a bunch of websites that have
some aspect in them that meets to the
particular problem you're trying to
design with your website or your your
graphical job and one of the things you
might do as a computer scientist it's
not just look at the surface of the
website but you might want to actually
go in and say I like that effect I like
that piece of it how did they build that
I want to open the source code and look
at it try and do that with haptics first
of all you can't find the applications
and the examples and then if you can
it's very hard to break into them and
see how they were constructed and it
might be a hardware thing it might be a
software thing it might be a whole
software architecture
think about how the the the signals are
being transferred through a whole system
very likely your haptics are part of a
larger system that included graphic it's
an audio maybe virtual reality
environment and it's all a big interlink
system and it's very hard to deconstruct
all of that so there's all these
problems but I'm going to talk about one
particular problem that doesn't even get
that far which is talking about it or
being able to describe it so usually if
you're a half dicks engineer or a
haptics designer you are stuck with the
the parameters that you have knobs to
turn ok which is I'm going to I'm going
to talk for the first little while about
vibrotactile feedback which is not my
personal favorite medium of haptics it's
not the most expressive or rich or where
we want to be eventually but for the
purpose it's sort of like laboratory
biologists who study on a Drosophila fly
platform it's it's there it's
manipulative it's something we can study
if even if it's not exactly where we
want to be at the end of the day so if
you're trying to do a vibrotactile
sensation this is basically what you got
okay
this is these are the knobs you can turn
that's what you can do and then you have
the IND user and the end user is
thinking of things like this is a really
urgent signal or that this thing feels
chunky here or I it sounds like a
motorcycle or I want it to be something
that I can feel when I'm running and I'm
sweating and my body is moving around
and and this these these are very
different than what the designer has to
work with and so this is a big
disconnect and part of what we've tried
to do is say well is there some way you
can bridge that disconnect can we
actually make a design language but is
closer to what this guy is thinking
rather than what this guy is forced to
think right now can you let this guy
work in this language okay so what would
that take so this is one piece of work
that my former PhD student now dr. sigh
he is a Max Planck Institute now did was
working with a visualization expert
tried to get past the fact that it's
geno like when we're feeling haptic
sensations you can only feel one
time when you can only concentrate on
one at time being able to attach
metadata to them through a great deal of
user studies and then be able to
visualize them not by looking at the
actual signals but by looking at their
arrangement relative to each other in
different facets different ways that I
might want to think about it and so the
particular facets that she came up with
were physical view emotion metaphors and
usage examples of these after a great
deal of talking to users seemed to be
the the ways you could sort all the
different words and terminologies that
people would use when their she was in
the context of into user customization
when she was doing this that that would
be that that would cover the basis and
then if you could actually rate she
created a large library of sensations
and organized them so what you see here
this is called vibe is it's a
visualization tool that you can access
online and it's an interface to a large
library and has these different views
and the little dots are the whole
library in each of these views and when
you filter in one view you can see the
same filtering on other one so it's a
standard of linked visualization but the
idea is that now you can browse and you
can actually look at the same stimulus
and see where it shows up relative to
other things and you can find neighbors
in different places you can drill in and
look at the actual sensation the time
course of it a graphical thing and you
can actually play it on an attacker and
so the idea is that this this is a
browsing interface that we then could
use it was a product of a lot of
research but then we can actually use it
in a lot of research in this highly
understood library is something that we
have it's an asset that we used and it's
it's available online and is actually
being used by a couple of companies so
that is an example of browsing but it
has terrible limits for example you
can't modify you can't move if you
actually want a sensation that's halfway
between a couple of things we don't have
anyway well we do in later work but as
at the time of this library you couldn't
say I have a sensation here in here and
I actually want something partway in a
perceptual morph between them and that
is something that we have done since
then but editing and sharing would be
another design activity
that we sent so so part of this was
really we were making all these tools
over the years and we started to say
well let's actually try and locate our
tools in these different design stages
and see what is special about these
different design stages that was a
browse tool but then in detailed design
here's one that another recent PhD
student oliver schneider built oliver is
now on the job market intent and he's he
built macaron he likes to name all his
work after cookies turns out and so
making a powerful editing tool we've
made lots of editing tools in our lab
this one he had an ulterior motive he
wanted to use it as a research tool to
study a particular premise which was
about use of examples in design and see
how people's design process changed
depending on their access to examples
both at a superficial level and a deep
level if you actually opened the
examples up so here's an example of what
a tool like that might look for look
like user actions to capture and
illustrate their design process finding
users followed an archetypal process
with examples facilitating design and
helping users learn we also report
several lessons for future design points
[Music]
okay so so the point there was that he
actually made something where we
actually took the same the same viral
tactile stimuli that were collected in
that other library and made them
available in an editing tool so that you
can go and actually open them up and
then he actually studied through immense
amount of qualitative work watch people
on a design tasks and segmented the
different things they were doing and
looked at the how the activities changed
depending on their access to examples so
so we found that this tool however was
actually very effective for other things
we used it we adapted this tool about
six times I think four different other
kinds of design jobs including robot
motion expressive robot motion when you
need something as a refinement as
opposed to the initial sketching part
and we have some other tools that were
more for the sketching part
so that's just a couple of examples of
different things we can do here we have
tools that are in all of these sections
quite a few that I can't for time
actually talk about but I want to talk
about the create step in a different
context that's not vibrotactile which is
more we we said we have done all this
work on robots that you touch effective
robots and I'm going to use that example
to talk about the create design stage
and some of the tools that we've
developed they're so effective touch so
giving another little bit of background
so we've done all this work on
communication functional communication
with vibrotactile signals and other
things and there's a immense amounts of
stuff we've done on attention and
learning your ability to learn signals
and meanwhile the the whole thing about
effective touch started around 2010 when
we started I started to read and notice
literature about you know studies where
we'd see that you know people's outcomes
after cardiac surgery were highly linked
to the fact of whether they had a dog at
home or not and trying to say well was
that because they took the dog for a
walk more and they got more exercise or
having the dog connected them to other
people and there were social attributes
or you had a cat was it because you had
to take care of the cat and feed it and
that made a difference how much of it
could have been the touching part and
and if some of it was due to the
touching part what was going on there
and how would you study that and can you
reproduce it and I'm just curious okay
didn't even have any applications of
mine we're just curious and about the
same time I had a PhD student come and
someone to work with me a potential PhD
student in his story was this is in 2009
steve johanna and he sat in my office as
well I had this girlfriend and she had a
cat and I really liked the cat and then
the girlfriend left me I really missed
the cat and I'm trying to figure out
what it was about the cat that was so
important and I thought okay we have to
go down this this line that's just so
weird and and of course at the time it
was kind of weird but now there's a lot
of people looking at effective robots
that was a process where we actually
went and built a number of robots over
the years and tried to actually study
these in a robot platform and so I'm
gonna give you first the dead simple
model of human robot interaction that we
proposed in 2009 and have not finished
squeezing the juice out of it yet it
looks simple but it's not okay so here's
the idea is that you have the person and
you have the robot and the person does a
simple thing which you just it's like
imagine there's a dog over here but
we're making it be a robot and you touch
your pet you do something you display a
motion in some way through your hand to
the robot what does the robot do the
robot has to perceive the touch and
somehow decide what that touch is the
robot has to decide what that touch
means what did the person intend by that
touch was it a happy touch was an
affection touch was it a corrective
touch is the person mad at me is a
person trying to make me feel better
okay and then the robot has a
personality or an agenda if it's a
therapy robot it might be a robot that
really wants to go to sleep right now or
it might be a puppy that wants to play
or it might be one that's got a job to
do which is to somehow do something with
the person and that will do the robot
then decides with whatever AI you put
into it what its response to this is
going to be and then the robot has to
render something based on what the robot
is capable of doing what degrees of
freedom the robot might have they might
have very limited display capitals so
they might have very powerful display
capability to somehow robot needs to
translate to I'm going to display this
emotion and then this is how I'm going
to do it given what I have available to
me and then the RO the human does the
same thing and perceives and processes
and reacts and so you have this virtuous
loop going on where they're both
affecting each other it's bi-directional
and maybe just maybe you're can actually
deliberately change what's happening in
here as a result of what you're doing
over here so that was the challenge we
set before ourselves and we thought well
this is a robot this is a machine not a
real animal this is why we did it oh but
it's not real animals so we can actually
do
one of these things at a time and try
and break the problem down a little bit
and so we built robots and we studied
this part and we studied that part and
then we tried very carefully to put them
together and do a loop and see if we
could make something happen there and I
don't have time to talk in great depth
about all these things there's about six
or eight papers and chunks of work and a
whole bunch of robots involved here but
the answer was that yes we were able to
break a lot of these things down and we
were able to do it I should first back
up can in this room can I assume that
everyone knows what effect is raise your
hand if you kind of know what effect is
so most but not a hundred percent so has
anyone as everyone maybe not everyone
has seen a model of effect this is one
this is a version of one of the most
common models of effect that's out there
it's a very simple model it doesn't
capture everything that captures some
things to a useful degree so you have
two dimensional two dimensions arousal
and valence which basically is saying
which direction and how much how strong
a third dimension that is sometimes used
is dominance which would be orthogonal
to this and the idea is that you can
actually place most of the words we use
to describe emotion somewhere on this
space dominance would distinguish for
example distressed versus furious okay
where you have a more aggressive aspect
to a high arousal negative valence
emotion and you can imagine when you
think about a robot that you're making
you might build a robot that is capable
of displaying distress but to have the
capacity to display rage or anger or
hostility you might actually need
different degrees of freedom else we
have not yet built a robot that has
teeth or hackles well actually we have
but not not in the main line of research
it was more offshoot and as a result it
was very hard to do the dominance
dimension we would need to build a
different machine for that and one of
the reasons for that is that one of our
target audiences was kids and it wasn't
clear that we wanted to snarl at the kid
and so there probably are occasions when
that would be appropriate but like put
me down I don't like that
but we haven't gotten there yet so so
one of some of the challenges we have
just purely building building these
robots and making them work as
experimental machines where to be
rendering and a recognizable emotion
State on the robot to be able to sense
the person's effect type over there
before or during an interaction either
directly on the robot or by taking other
information that you might have from
other sources and integrating that into
the information our Holy Grail is to get
everything out of the robot interaction
itself so through a touching itself so
that you don't have to for example
making a kid who's having an emotional
meltdown put on their physio sensors or
something which is not going to work too
well and then changing the person's
emotion state so very quickly this is an
early robot I have this intact actually
the first one this is about the third
one that we built this was came into
being around 2010 what we had to work
with in was FSR force sensitive
resistors pasted on a fiberglass shell
we call this the turtle with a fur coat
it wasn't really where we wanted to be
on sensing because at the time you can
obviously see what the issues here are
going to be not only are the problems
with the tactility on it it doesn't feel
right with the with the fiberglass but
we needed the hard surface to get a good
sense signal out of the sensors which
since suppressor but the big problem was
that you weren't picking up anything in
between we had accelerometer to get
vibrations from taps and that worked
pretty well but this was very
unsatisfying as a sensing system but it
was the best we could do at the time
with the technology and we did a lot of
research on that you could buy very high
quality flexible sensors at the time for
robot fingertips and they cost something
on the a few thousand per square
centimeter and when I wanted to just
saran wrap a large surface and I didn't
want to pay fifty thousand dollars to do
so and so that was just not avail and I
didn't need that kind of resolution on
the display side this robot could make
breathing movements it could do
something with the ears that expressed
arousal and it had a heartbeat and it
sounds very simple we iterated a lot
with many other haptic sketches to
arrive at those and you would
surprised how well it worked using this
robot we were able to render emotions
recognizable II into all the quadrants
of that effect grid but and that was
like yay but but it wasn't very useful
as an interaction because we couldn't
move from one to another and there's a
whole it didn't have the right
affordances so for example around this
time people would come in the lab and
they would see this robot saying wow
that's really cool and you know I have a
kid with autism and I bet this would
really be great for them I saying oh how
and what would you do with it and they
would say oh well you should talk to my
doctor and the doctor wouldn't be a
researcher and that would be the end of
it and and meanwhile we were saying well
that's interesting and we got interested
in anxiety disorders and we started to
work with kids with anxiety disorders
the challenge there was we wanted well
there's two challenges one listen as
anyone in the room ever recent worked
with kids and an experimental context a
few people have you ever had to try and
change a kid's emotion okay so maybe you
can sympathize with me on this one so I
had a situation for okay I want to get a
kid really stressed out and see if I can
calm him down and all under ethical
review and so this was we tried for
quite a while we gave it a good a good
try and it was one thing was the kids
don't follow instructions I should have
seen that one coming as a parent of ages
kids in this age but so it's very hard
to make them follow a experimental
protocol that didn't go too well but
also as hard to actually get them into a
state of deep anxiety so that we could
actually then try and give them what we
thought was a pill that would calm them
down essentially an interaction here we
tried lots of things I know about all we
could manage was to get them into a flow
state which worked really well but
wasn't what we were after so we ended up
going back and working with adults which
we could take more liberties with and
and found some great results in terms of
being able to actually change their
emotional state and discovered in the
process that the breathing motions
actually there was something going on
with the breathing is very powerful and
very hardwired and so much so that we
now have another spin-off project which
is in its final stages of clinical
trials right now
in the pediatric intensive care unit at
Maine Children's Hospital in BC which is
basically this thing turned inside-out
it's now just a platform that goes up
and down and you put it in the incubator
but premature infant which might be this
big is lying on and when the baby is
stuck with needles and cause pain which
then cause brain damage a slight slight
cumulative brain damage that leads to
negative outcomes this breathing motion
actually mitigates those pain responses
and the baby does not have those adverse
effects and there is something about the
breathing and we thought of doing this
because the standard of care has become
actually allowing the baby on the
mother's chest and we basically have
shown that we can get the same benefits
in a premature infant of being on the
mother of being on a moving platform so
can we actually duplicate and reproduce
some of the effects of haptic touch with
a machine it appears that we can even if
you don't have any emotional attachment
to the machine and it's just a hardwired
motion at this point we thought well we
need to things differently we need
interaction design we need to actually
also one of the things we learned from
the kids was that when you show them the
robot this first one I could show them
this one and they say oh I love it and
they want to pick it up and I hold it
and they talk about it and then they say
where is it from what is it why does it
have any eyes what is that cord
what's tail why this tail plugged into
the wall the data tether data and power
tether in this case and when I turn the
power off and the engines die and the
thing kind of goes would they say oh it
died and and we realize pretty soon it's
like oh we need a narrative the
narrative is really important for this
robot and people bring a story or you
have to give a story it doesn't matter
there needs to be some kind of a story
and later more recently there's a paper
we have at Kai coming out which we've
taken this line quite a bit further is
that we can have a very strong influence
on how you interpret the emotion
rendering based on the narrative that is
applied to the robot so any ambiguity
gets resolved by what the person thinks
is going on and either the person brings
a narrative or
give the narrative but there is a story
and that is the frame in which you
interpret what's happening here which is
exactly what people do if you're trying
to decide when your partner comes down
for breakfast in the morning and they're
grumpy are they just tired and had a bad
night's sleep or is he mad at me for
something will be dependent very much on
whether we had a fight before or not for
example like I might bring a narrative
to it which helps me interpret and then
how I resolve the ambiguity is I will
probe I will inquire I will ask
something I will say something that well
then the response will help to clarify
it and so we started to do our
interaction design thinking much more
about narrative context and probing and
interrogating and resolving it that way
so so we wanted to build do interaction
design instead of rendering these static
emotions and so we needed to say well
okay we developed a new use case which
was we're trying to access stress out
kids we found a great solution which was
actually to go into the children's
intensive care that when the waiting
room for pediatric surgery the
anesthesiologist wanted help they said
the kids come in they're terrified we
have to stick a needle in them and make
them go to sleep and if they fight us
this is bad they have they don't go
under easily and then the surgery
doesn't go as well and the recovery is
not as good if we can actually calm them
down without having to give them drugs
that would be great and if you have a
way to do that that would be awesome
so we said great we don't have to stress
the gifts out they're already stressed
out and so are their parents their
parents are the ones who are really
actually one of the things I figured out
it's the parents you need this more than
the kids and and so and the parents are
making the kids be stressed out so
remember that if you have our kid going
under surgery so so we thought well if
we're gonna do this in this environment
we we need a real robot not just one
that computer science grad students are
building and so we went to a
professional design firm and said we
want this thing and I can give you
engineering specs but I'd rather we kind
of figure out you know open the box and
try and think of new ways to do it it
needs to breathe and it needs to kind of
huddle and it needs to be able to be
open for business kind of yoga inspired
movements and it needs to be able to
give an orienting response all
these things and help us build it and
the engineering firm was good they
thought this was a really fun project
they usually built medical instruments
and things like that so the hospital
environment didn't faze them at all but
they really did not have the right
process for this and we're not able to
do an iterative lots of sketching and
then converge on an expressive design
because we were really trying to design
expressive movements and it was very
hard to give strict engineering specs
for that say this was a very expensive
learning experience for me and so we did
not never having this that robot in a
study and said we decided to go back it
was not effective in displaying emotion
it was just kind of weird the things
didn't work together so we embarked on a
whole nother journey which was to let's
just take one degree of freedom at a
time and just really understand all the
things you could do with it and for that
we needed to do a very iterative process
so go to town and we wanted to do things
that would be quite I don't think this
one has sound in it so this was at Kai
last year and so this is my student Paul
Buchi mostly along with a couple of
other students in the group and the idea
was to use haptic sketching and actually
develop design systems that we could
quickly iterate so even you bring a
subject in and they didn't like
something we could build another one
right on the spot or even or perhaps
coming back the next day and so what he
had to do was he spent a whole lot of
time just trying to figure out the kinds
of movements that would be expressive
here we decide studies that I'm showing
you here are about breathing we're
currently doing design studies on many
other degrees of freedom that are
displaying other things here so we're
talking about periodic motion but might
express things that ma'am
would be recognizable from mammalian
breathing and so you ended up coming up
with a couple of models and the idea
here is you want to something that's
very cheap and quick to iterate but also
is robust and so so generally he went to
this family of flexure so there's some
compliance in the mechanism in the in
the body and it wants to spring back to
a particular shape and then you use the
motor to push against that so it has a
passive state and then what you have is
this really cheap motor that doesn't
have to be very fast or
good we can be super simple that is is
working on compression and and therefore
you can you can throw these things
against the wall or step on them and
they won't break they're very tough and
they're cheap and a kid can make it we
have kids camps and they come in and
they get to make their own cuddle BOTS
and they can customize and make them
different they're really they're really
easy to make and so there's a couple
different systems here one is made out
of wood pieces that you can laser print
and laser cut and and iterate very
quickly that way you can scale them or
put little features on them or make them
lopsided or whatever and the other is
just made out of plastic that you print
on a piece of plastic and then cut out
and so they're pretty quick to iterate
so these these design systems but at the
same time realizing that so one of the
reasons we wanted to iterate so fast was
that the behavior and the motion need to
be designed at the same time so so how
it moves and how it can move and it
turns out it's very hard to sell now we
saw those all those motions how did we
actually create those motions well it's
not so easy and one of the things for
example that we saw that people really
wanted to do we bring subjects in and
say how do you want it to move or if you
want it to show let it scared you know
what should it do and they would say Oh
had it like I I can't program it in code
and they were certain vocalizing they
would make I wanted go or I wanted to do
this this sound and and they would use
their body to make these sounds and so
we went with that so these are these are
some of the different tools we actually
use including you know using audio to
source sounds and then play those out as
a starting point or the verbalizations
and I'll just show you an example of one
project which was about using voice when
describing something abstract like
motion many people may find themselves
at a loss for words
I mean opted to use non word
vocalizations to express themselves
we don't translate some properties of
your voice into motion on a one degree
of freedom robot yeah
and amplitude and interprets them
according to a set of user definable
parameters with luteal users can quickly
naturally sketch effective behaviors in
a unique conversational design space so
that was I was really proud of that
project that was an undergrad a
researcher who did that and presented it
at this last year and got a prize and
that was kind of fun
so so what you see there is this really
difficult seppo and I guess I've
demonstrated this work myself at a
conference and I can separate the world
into people who will bark at a robot in
public and people who will not do that
under any any circumstance but love to
walk it to other people doing it just
another category so and then okay we
talked about experimentation so we were
trying to decide how expressive it was
so this is one of the kinds of studies
we do where we we did a participatory
design with professional voice actors
people who are actually good at
modulating their voice well I think one
was a singer in - were actually theatre
people and this so we take our
two-dimensional effect grid and say over
three sessions where they would play
around with this system and then say I
want you to change the system to make it
more expressive and they would actually
say well what if you do this with my
voice and I want a robot that can do
this and we would iterate on both boodle
and the robots and they come back and
they do it again and this is just
showing that over three visits they
would draw these are the spaces on the a
figure that they felt they could reach
when they if they wanted to do something
they could make the robot do that they
had that expressive control and you can
just basically see that over time with
these iterations through some hard to
quantify combination of experience and
improvement in the tools and the robots
they were able to get more proficient or
more capable of it over over the time so
so that would be a create tool so the
combination of Buddha land the whole
cuddle bit system and all this was this
whole big launch to try and say creating
expressive movement now if we want to
edit that movement that we've sketched
then we use something like macaron that
editor and go in tweak it once you've
laid down the first track you want to go
in and tweak it so that's one thing and
so I just want to touch brief
the sensing side which I talked about
this this bottom part of the display so
here's I told I showed you those FSR on
the is that actually playing so this is
a first sensor so we had this problem
I'm wanting to really pick up delicate
touches so this work is by owner flag
was a master student who is now a
reporter for Al Jazeera so you can
actually see that you in a different
direction after this and the shoes you
would see how this works or guess how it
works
[Music]
so this is actually inspired by some
work by Lea nucleate MIT which so this
photograph is Lea's working on ours to
do a better job of showing that on this
picture but the idea was that you
actually have a piece of fabric this is
conductive thread that you've woven
through it you have collectors at the
inn so you can make a circuit and the
way you change the resistance across
this very simple circuit is you scruff
the threads together they have different
amounts of contact and that changes the
resistance across the circuit in a
stochastic way that you can then train
of so that's what she did says oh look
you could make a resistor that changes
what we did was we took it a whole lot
farther and applied machine learning to
it and actually showed that you could
actually distinguish lots of different
kinds of touches by training it and the
devil is in the details to actually turn
a very simple concept into an effective
sensor by getting the exact proportions
of threads and how that all works and we
found it work best if you have you know
varying lexa lengths of threads and it's
more expressive and you can actually
collect a lot more detail and so early
on when we had the first robot we
developed something we called a touch
library a touch dictionary that had I
think about eighty touches all the
different ways that people ever touched
our robot so we collected frequency data
of it from all kinds of videos studies
and these are the highest frequency
touches that people would main so we
kind of take this smaller set for do a
lot of our studies and so what we saw
with this sensor is that this is the
kind of recognition accuracy that we
could do on touches of these different
kinds of touches so basically almost a
hundred percent distinguishing using
this simple sensor but this is really
cool unlike that we were hoping for this
one was a complete shock so here's a
different touches I think this had 15
subjects this is how well we could tell
which person was touching it so not only
could we always tell what touch was
being made there was within that there
was enough individual difference in way
of touching that we could say who was
touching it with not very much training
so so that was actually like what you
could actually have the robot just from
time
not from sound or voice or anything like
that we actually know who's petting it
right now that's pretty interesting so
we went on to make a different kind of
sensor as well this is a very
inexpensive fabric sensor that uses
electrically striped fabric in different
layers and you make taxes that are about
a finger pad size large and just saran
wrap robots on it so we've come a long
way from the FSR and we're now also
collaborating with a group in Germany
Max Planck who is doing the same idea
but in printable printable electronics
that are our gels that you can just
layer onto things and are more
customizable this and working on making
different shapes and kind of make design
tools to actually print these these
sensors and so we can do all kinds of
stuff with that
so I out of time so I won't go into the
many things that we're doing here but
these systems that are then customizable
and working on making tools to so you
can actually design and print these
sensors and put them on different shapes
and then you can not just on robots but
on you know different objects so you
might want to have an object that I put
in my pocket and I fiddle around with it
and I can tell your emotion and do some
kind of intervention because of the way
you're fidgeting with something is
that's one of the the things that we're
actually going for here and then have
these in a way that people who want to
play around with it can customize it and
do their own version of it so trying to
go back to the accessible haptics we
have all these tools okay that I can you
know link into a design framework to say
there's these different kinds of things
different design stages that we use
there's a lot more that I didn't talk
about here and and these are all you
know we put them on our website and
we've got them on github and people can
do that but how can we really help
people design better and so the next
kind of phase of research that we're
really trying to do now is really to go
directly at the problem of making it
accessible and putting out there and
understanding designers we've done some
studies of designers but now we're
trying to look at different kinds of
designers and trying to create an online
repository of tools that people can
build and customize and develop so that
we can start to
break this obstacle of creating content
and creating devices so - trying to make
oh yeah this slide is messed up okay so
so thinking about the design ecosystem
which is differs by what your design
purpose is what your knowledge and
background is and but giving access to
it so for all these this is the
framework and we're trying to support a
larger audience and so we're developing
a open haptic repository you won't find
anything at that location yet it's it's
under development but the idea is that
so far we have a lot of haptic devices
we have a lot of tools we're trying to
bring other people into it it's not
supposed to be just artwork the whole
point is its it's going to be a public
open access thing I was just spent the
day yesterday at Mozilla actually
talking with them about how you launch a
system like that and what role they
might like to play in helping us launch
an open access portal like this more of
an Arduino model where maybe you
download designs yourself or you can
have someone pay for them these are some
of the things that we're working on
right now that would be part of the
population here so we have hardware a
few pieces of hardware that I am not
talking about right now some of it were
actually both of these things we're
demonstrating it half the Coptics
conference in March in San Francisco
which I can give a plug for if you want
to go out there there's software so the
backend software that lets you actually
prototype things on devices that you may
have made yourself
we've run student design challenges
where we put those tools out there and
support student designers and they
actually study the student designers to
see what kind of problems they have plus
the student designers generate all these
designs that we can then also post and
haptic device library and this is a case
where we've been very frustrated that
there's all these going back to the
nineteen ninety all these inventions
that people have made of haptic devices
and I've long enough in the tooth now
that when young people come to me and
say Karen can you tell me all the
pantograph designs that are out there
and I'm gonna there's five or six but I
can't even remember who they all are and
that's like one of the most common
second isms there should be an online
place where people can go in browse a
lot of this stuff was actually invented
before we but you know those papers are
not even available online so it's very
hard and someone said people have to go
and invent it all over again and so
we're trying to figure out if you make
if you find all those inventions and you
post them
how can you visualize and browse them so
if I'm looking for something like I want
to make a wearable device and I want
these attributes and I want to find
designs that are suitable for low-power
wearable applications in a particular
way and you want to find stuff where the
original designers weren't thinking of
those attributes when they did it so
we're trying to collect the designs and
then expert source annotations on them
so that we can actually visualize and
browse these kinds of things so it's
actually a big community projects that's
involving the whole haptic design
community to help contribute annotations
as well as designs and then a big
project that actually started with
Allison and O camera here at Stanford
but we're continuing on our own is
educational tech that'll learn physical
concepts using haptics and understanding
the value of that by working with
educational experts and now we have all
these different designers which are the
students who are playing around with
stuff in building systems they're gonna
feel but teachers who are helping to
build the sand boxes in the third party
designers who are trying to content eyes
them and do this all with extremely low
cost technology that could be successful
in a classroom environment so that's
another big push that we're doing and
we'll be a driver for some of that so
that's where I'll stop in I just wanted
to do a little plug we're doing a big
big development at UBC which is the the
designing for people research cluster we
have a new graduate training program for
PhD students and advanced masters
masters who want to do research so it's
not an industry professional masters
it's really for researchers and it's
very interdisciplinary you guys have a
great interdisciplinary group but I can
go and better we actually have eight
departments not three or four and we
have about 80 or 100 people coming to
our lunch sessions which are only once a
month not every week and and so what
we're really trying to do is band
together to both solve these hard
interdisciplinary
and have collaborations to do that but
also to help train graduate students in
a way that they can integrate those
different perspectives and I rarely take
these very broad views and to help with
this knowledge mobilization issue where
we have all this knowledge that we're
trying to get out there in the world and
trying to find different ways to
capitalize on that by working together
so there's a lot of activity going on in
that at UBC right now so I'll stop there
and hopefully you guys have some
questions my students great really
exciting work that you've been doing I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit more about I know you didn't talk
about it in this talk but about how the
studies you've been doing about context
and effective how that changes
perception and so how obvious ly our
perception is guided not only by the
sensory information that we have but
also the context yeah we're
understanding but I'm also wondering
like how far in the stuff you guys have
done so far how far can push it in terms
of changing perceived effect based on
just this story or the context yeah
there's there's two ways to look at this
context question and one is in deep
frustration is like man it's really hard
to control what people sense because the
context like if I can't control the
contest I have no idea how they're gonna
interpret it so that's kind of a
discouraging way to think about it and
then the other way it's like wow I can
really get away with a lot in the haptic
display because context is so important
it can and you can actually dominate it
but then you need to have some insight
into what the context is or some way of
controlling it or the approach that
we're taking is more to try and think of
it as interactions where people will
reveal more and interrogate and follow
up and that it's something that actually
has to take place over time so so the
long-winded answer you know I showed you
this a phat grid of kind of these
discrete emotions and we've really over
the last few years have started
you know that's really not a very useful
for real real situations real situations
you're feeling complex emotions multiple
at a time it's not like oh right now I
am sad right now I am happy it's I might
be both of those things at once and what
we're really looking at more is Delta's
so if we can actually detect changes
over time then that's where the dirt is
that's where that's where the
interesting stuff is and so we're very
much trying to detect alterations and be
able to interpret those in terms of
context so so we've really departed from
that original one although it is a kind
of a grounding and a way of talking
about it and organizing your thoughts
still in terms of the narrative it's
funny just again at my forehead Mozilla
this stuff is already coming up all the
time all this stuff with IOT and
networked IOT and being able to collect
information from different sources so
we've focused more on touch because
that's kind of where we started but
there's a lot of information from other
sources including vocal prosody and
stuff you might getting from imagery and
video cameras and history knowledge past
knowledge of a particular individual and
you know some of the scenarios that we
have are for maybe putting these robots
with a child and their child is carrying
around like a stuffed animal and over
time you could build quite an elaborate
profile about you know patterns in the
child's life and I think that if you had
that and you could stomach all the huge
ethical issues that you're dealing with
at that point you could do some really
amazing things in terms of being able to
intelligently and for what's going on
that's getting much deeper into the AI
then I am you the expert on and so that
for me this would be collaborations with
other people who doing that more but I
think that that is if we're trying to
make extremely rich interactions that
that's kind of the direction you're
going I think it is you know being at
the patterns and and and personalization
actually understanding a particular
individual it's going to be very
important yeah so not a very satisfying
but can keep us busy for a long time
from the future by getting it out yes
okay just one more about why you new
should we chose ears or a mode of
expression and how it currently compares
to
something like breathing yeah so we
wanted of course we were doing ears and
breathing and strictly speaking they're
not ears because we actually tried very
hard to have it not be representational
and if I could show you some pictures of
some of the earlier prototypes we made
all these sketches and we've we kind of
figured out fairly early on made many
different shapes with many kinds of
appendages on them and we were trying so
hard to have them not look like real
animals we actually put these bumpy
things out like either end of a body so
that it really didn't look like ears at
that point and the feedback we got from
people was that know there needs to be -
and they need to be next to each other
because that's how what I want to do I
want to kind of stroke them like a dog's
ears
okay user centered design we will put
the ears together and then it looks like
it has a head and you're kind of stuck
with that so the reason we didn't want
to have a head was because we were
trying to really focus on the haptics
and the touch and so we were trying to
not make a visual focal point on the
object of course now as we're going into
these more interaction design things it
is actually helpful to have a visual for
example in the hospital environment we
will have a situation where the first
stage of the interaction is actually
getting the kid to pick the robot up and
so that's all visual so you were now
we're working on visual gesture at some
point you transfer over to haptic
gesture and so the ears are a useful
tool because they're very recognizable
as a way of indicating attention and
arousal level and so they're just we are
so well trained to understand interpret
years they're just very useful that way
both for touching and looking at so
we're kind of stuck with them the
current robots the the big degree of
freedom I'm really excited about right
now is a spine and so being able to do
this versus do this and have that
integrate with a breathing in still
having a very simple mechanism and so
we're kind of we're doing a lot of form
studies to first get the spine right
we've got a pretty good spine that does
all that but now we're trying to make it
work with the ribs breathing at the same
time and have that very very low degree
of freedom and very simple to build so
it's it's really I guess the the degrees
of freedom are very much out of how
people interpret them and being able to
cover the bases on the different kinds
of things we're trying to express
where they turn out to be useful instead
of spine instead of breathing yeah
pulse not so much people say pulse and
heat those the most common questions I
get and you think about pulse and
heartbeat and you think well how often
can you actually feel the pulse or
heartbeat in a creature that you're
interacting with and it's it has to be
pretty upset before you can actually
feel the heart pounding and so we
actually found that that's not as useful
a degree of freedom but purring is super
valuable you can do lots and lots
whispering it's very complementary to
breathing so we and it's very easy to do
you can just you know make it Rumble and
and it's so that's that's a that's a
keeper as well please just come up to
the phone I'm sure she's happy
[Applause]
you